You're not a glutton, ant, you're a glutton with a delicious bow.
For the first time,
I thought that I wanted to give back to someone I'm a
transcendent fool Even
if I'm treated like a fool or scolded a lot, I don't want to give up I don't care about anything, just one word is enough I want my master to praise me
Hey,
then, I
'll make
you say 'gafun' to that stingy [ __ ] What is the most embarrassing desire you don't want to tell people
?
What is it?
[Music]
I'm human, and
even though I'm different from everyone else, I still want to
be with them.
It's hot, let's go home for a minute, it's being
eaten
[music] I
've arrived at Babils,
isn't it?
But it'll be alright
Someday,
an archer like you've never seen before will
appear